let's talk about paddling students on
the but kind of a weird topic for a
political show but it's what a school in
Georgia wants to do a school in Georgia
has sent out consent forms to parents
asking for permission to reinstate the
paddling of students on the rear end as
punishment there are many people who are
outraged but there are also parents in
the district who are pleased one-third
of the parents at this school reportedly
signing the consent forms so to
understand this story you have to
understand the term strict father
morality this is something I've talked
about on the program many times this is
something that exists among the right
which exposes that even though they care
to claim about policy they don't really
care about the best possible policy they
care about what feels fair to them or
what feels like justice to them and for
them justice usually means consequences
that feel good there's this phrase
that's become popularized I guess it's
been popularized by ben shapiro although
i'm not totally sure facts don't care
about your feelings it turns out that
for the right there approach is our
feelings are more important than the
facts so let me give you an example of
that and then i'll tell you how it
applies to the paddling of students in
georgia schools the right claims to be
against abortion and to want to reduce
the number of abortions they say to zero
that's great there's actually a lot of
people on the left and the right that
would agree on that let's reduce the
number of abortions to zero or as close
to zero as possible it happens that we
know how to do it comprar has
comprehensive sex education and no cost
access to contraceptives the right is
against that the right wants abortion
bans no sex ed and no access to
contraceptives why because a so-called
strict father would say if you have
non-procreative sex then you deserve to
get pregnant and if you do get pregnant
you deserve
to carry the baby to term and then to
raise it when it comes to crime another
example we know that stricter
punishments don't deter crime the threat
of a stricter punishment doesn't deter
serious crime and I recently did a lot
of reading about this and it turns out
that the threat of the death penalty for
a particular crime compared to the
threat of life in prison doesn't deter
crime harsher prison sentences versus
lighter prison sentences don't reduce
recidivism rates but the write claims
that they do and they want those harsher
sentences because it feels morally right
and morally just the people who
committed the crime deserve the
punishments and along the same lines we
know that physically punishing children
is not a good thing in the long term but
there are parents who continue to
physically punish their kids and there
is now a school in Hephzibah or
Hephzibah not sure how it's pronounced
in Georgia set home consent forms
telling parents that if they want they
can sign off on the new policy of using
paddles to punish students paddling
means spanking a kid on the butt with a
wooden board and according to the
superintendent 1/3 of parents agreed to
have the school paddle their kids as
necessary they explained how it will
work which is that the student will be
taken into an office behind closed doors
the students will place their hands on
their knees or a piece of furniture and
will be struck on the buttocks with a
paddle only after the third offense this
is a choice it's not just strict father
morality this is a choice for what's
easy over what works you paddle a kid it
really seems like you're doing something
and then you send them back to class
they might be embarrassed
maybe they'll behave a little better in
the short term but the reality is that
the behavior issues are often coming
because of what's going on in the home
or upbringing or family situations or
other factors paddling a kid doesn't
deal with the underlying issues
some parts of this country have figured
that out other parts of this country are
still in the dark ages and that is truly
horrifying and scary and I don't know if
I should be pleased that two-thirds of
the parents in hepzibah Georgia didn't
sign the paddling consent form or
horrified that one third did I lean
towards being horrified that one third
did